cómo enseñar la inquisición estudiantes
en españa'
empecemos con nuestros valores humanos
en nuestra sociedad debemos respetar la
diversidad entre personas personas de
diferentes credos y creencias herencias
y también estilos de vida a nosotros nos
toca fomentar la convivencia en cuanto a
la inquisición debemos luchar en contra
del olvido y estudiar la historia con
motivo de recuperar los valores del
pluralismo y la diversidad cultural que
se han reprimido
cual es el elemento básico de la
convivencia la amistad he repasado
muchos registros históricos de la época
de la inquisición y para mí los hombres
saliente es la amistad que existía en
muchos pueblos entre personas de
diferentes credos antes la llegada de la
inc
al novelista
haruki murakami se atribuye la frase
nuestro sentido de la responsabilidad
nace de la imaginación
creo que una novela bien fundamentada en
la realidad histórica
contribuye a conformar el futuro y
también
conmover e inspirar a nuestros jóvenes
así nació mi novela histórica los
cantiles de albarracín y para los
estudiantes mi cortometraje educativo
disponible gratis a los maestros de la
secundaria y los institutos
vemos la última expresión de la sociedad
multicultural del reino de aragón a
finales del siglo 15 esa expresión tan
preciosa de una sociedad multicultural
y ahora os invito viajar conmigo al
siglo 15 al reino de aragón por medio de
una historia de amistad entre jóvenes y
la llegada de la inquisición a su tierra
aquí vemos a sara es una niña judía que
se hace mujer cuando la inquisición se
establece en el reino de aragón
racing es donde regresarán donde tiene a
sus amigos judíos cristianos y
musulmanes
ella cumple los 14 años cuando la
inquisición
entra en aragón los inquisidores se
fijan en sara por motivos misteriosos la
trasladan a las ciudades para pasar al
convento de santa inés de los dominicos
un convento que existía en aquella época
la madre superiora trata de convertirla
al cristianismo pero ahora se resiste
[Música]
y aragón con la ayuda de amigos
musulmanes usar una judía se viste de
musulmana
fátima la amiga de saná la cabalgando en
la mula con una gatita negra y la caja
tendrá sus aventuras de gato
[Música]
por el camino llevan sus carriles
fátima tiene un arte estos candiles al
estilo califal de córdoba
el cadí les hará un candil al estilo
sefardí con un diseño de mejora y del
olivo sagrado
ahora vamos a cruzar la sierra con ellos
el viaje empieza en la sierra de
albarracín al suroeste de aragón es una
región de leyendas y tradiciones
leyendas de brujas de tradiciones de
mayo y del solsticio y también peligrosa
porque en el siglo 15 andaba por allí
lobos salvajes
para viajar con su amiga fátima y la tía
y el primer maravilla con la protección
de ella anda de mateos y sus compañeros
son unos animales de albarracín de viaje
a la costa valenciana con destino a
túnez
[Música]
ya está huyendo de los dos niños y sus
amigos a proteger la tiene que
presentarse como la guerra donde es
fácil y alojarse con ellos en la casa
también es musulmanas
aprender muchas costumbres musulmanas
por el camino siendo fiel a su identidad
sus
diferencias entre ellos surgen la
amistad y la comprensión
surge el amor empieza y un joven dominio
del linaje de nombre dice libres al
principio cuando el joven empieza a
declarar sus intenciones
sara exclama pero by vicente no te pases
[Música]
mi novela pone de relieve la cuestión de
la dignidad y la tonalidad de las
interacciones humanas
después de las ventas y perseguidos por
la santa y sus amigos llegan
[Música]
rumbo al desconocidos de las aguas
en el agua vi reflejada a una mujer
joven con atuendo emocional sola tan
esbelta y derecha como una extremista
cuyos ojos hubieran podido reflejar la
fe de cualquiera de nuestras tres
religiones mi propio reflejo me dijo
aragón es mi tierra soy tan aragonesa
como cualquiera más y departir para
mantener mi fe
no fue la primera
cuantos han de seguir
[Música]
el reino del árbol fue una potencia en
europa en la década de 1.480 fueron los
conversos sefardíes quienes manejaban
una gran parte del comercio marítimo a
lunes los conversos eran de linaje judío
y se habían convertido el judaísmo al
cristianismo
los judíos son un pueblo antiguo con
orígenes en la tierra de israel
en la edad media los judíos de
albarracín eran actores muy importantes
en la economía las industrias de
textiles cuero y calzado en el comercio
con tiendas y almacenes en la producción
de crédito a residentes de todos los
credos y también en servicios médicos y
no sólo en albarracín sino también por
todo el reino
en todo aragón los judíos tenían las
habilidades comerciales y financieras
más avanzadas
en el siglo 14 la sinagoga mayor de
zaragoza tuvo una de las congregaciones
judías más grandes de europa
ahora nada existe del edificio principal
pero os aseguro que fue toda una belleza
en mi novela vais a encontrar una
descripción auténtica del interior
un detalle de la génesis en el principio
creo dios los cielos y la tierra
y un mapa diseñado especialmente para
mis lectores es el mapa de los candiles
salvar la cima de todos los lugares
indicados en este mapa son parte de mi
novela
a fines del siglo 15 muchas áreas de
aragón tenían pueblos muy diversos
cristianos musulmanes judíos y personas
de herencia y félix estás aquí vemos
unas imágenes del patrimonio cultural de
la
de las bellas y gris las de los pueblos
históricos de la comarca de calatayud
mucho de la historia de sara transcurre
en la ciudad de calatayud donde su
hermana mayor y su esposo viven en un
palacete
del música de huesca la junta media que
les sale de mi historia como la hermana
mayor de sarah
de la ciudad capital zaragoza del
palacio de la aljafería de la mezquita
de toulouse y la comarca de tarazona de
la sinagoga de tierra de la comarca de
teruel
[Música]
vosotros conocéis a estas dos personas
los reyes católicos
ellos establecieron su propia
inquisición para eliminar entre sus
sujetos cristianos las actividades de
creencias no aceptadas por la iglesia
católica
si una persona de la fe cristiana no es
aplicada a jesucristo como el mesías su
alma estaría condenada para haciéndoles
y eso fue su justicia
justificación para condenar a los
herejes a la muerte
el inquisidor petro después llega a la
entrada a la catedral de la seo se
arrodilla para rezar y desde las sombras
y ya le claro muchos metros de largo es
el protegido de porque nada estaba
muerto quien se culpó un grupo de
líderes conversos sefardíes incluso en
el gran magistrados
[Música]
en memoria de su hija pedí un dibujo del
olivo sagrado para mí
una ciudad que se destaca en particular
por lograr la unidad es la ciudad de
teruel
un inquisidor diferente pues ya los
héroes
y ahora sorpresa esperándolo porque las
familias de teruel sabían que él vendría
cuando el inquisidor olivera llegó con
su partido desde tubos a las fuerzas de
teruel y el consejo municipal se negó a
dejarles ingresar
pero él se veía a sí misma como una
ciudad unida y se levantó para defender
a todos sus residentes de diferentes
credos la ciudad envió una carta al rey
fernando
explicó que su imagen es su majestad se
equivocó al enviar la inquisición porque
el juicio de las almas de los hombres
está reservado para el dios al final de
los tiempos
los reyes católicos reaccionaron con una
política de tierra quemada
todos esos eventos vemos por los ojos
césar a sus hermanos y sus amiguitos
hoy
aragón no es conocido en españa como un
centro principal de la cultura blanca
pero no es porque los judíos y los
conversos no eran importantes en aragón
sino porque eran los más resistentes
cuál es el mensaje en mi vida
a pesar de las injusticias de aquellos
tiempos
aprendí a no buscar a nadie por su fe
porque lo peor y lo mejor en todos
nosotros es lo mismo
mejor
[Música]
desde el reino de aragón en el siglo 15
una niña judía nos envía un mensaje de
luz un mensaje de hermandad un mensaje
muy importante
en el mundo de hoy
espero que os vaya a gustar muchos los
candiles de albarracín
es
[Música]